[Musique]
le conseil constitutionnel a indiqué
qu'il rendrait sa décision le 5 août
prochain
la loi sera donc promulguée dans la
foulée avec une entrée en vigueur que
nous prévoyons pour le neuf routes dès
lors que nous n'aurons plus besoin du
pass sanitaires pour lutter contre
l'épidémie
nous n'utiliserons plus le pass
sanitaires
[Musique]
27000 cas ont été recensés dans la
journée d'hier nous comptons désormais
plus de 19000 cas par jour en moyenne
ses 97 % de plus qu'il ya une semaine
et si cette progression a pu très
légèrement ralentir ces derniers jours
elle reste extrêmement élevé
la carte de france est désormais presque
entièrement rouge et elle est par
endroits rouge écarlate
[Musique]
la tension hospitalière est désormais en
hausse au niveau national le nombre de
patients hospitalisés est repassé au
dessus de 7000 et on compte 250 patients
hospitalisés de plus que la semaine
dernière le nombre de patients en
réanimation approche du seuil 2000 soit
20% de nos capacités totales avec un
nombre de passages qui a augmenté de 80%
en une semaine
[Musique]